today's draft guys who were traded and
were better
better with their new team than they
were with their when did it become that
you know the better part i mean you know
when you texted last night when you
texted last night what does that mean
and it was explained to you what it
means that's when it became that
that's exactly what i became the best
players ever being traded was the
original thing in lieu of john and it
was
and it was shifted to
i asked the question best after traded
the answer was yes you asked what did
that mean it was explained to you don't
give me that crap now are you already
throwing the towel is that what you're
doing are you throwing a towel because i
gotta i'm just saying
i don't like the explanation any of it
but don't worry i'm still going to whoop
your butt in this draft so let's go all
right since you're whining i'll let you
have the first pick
well i know since we're doing best
players after being traded okay
i think i have to lead that off with
brett favre i mean brett f the first
trade i mean brett favre was traded
twice
both kind of went good
right after but specifically the first
time when he went from the atlanta
falcons to the green bay packers i mean
come on i mean brett favre is an
all-time great he went to green bay and
you know how to sit on the bench for a
little bit don makowsky gets hurt he
comes in and see you don you're no
longer the magic man there's a new magic
man in town and brett favre took over
and then took took control of the whole
nfl i mean you could sit here and
certainly argue brett favre was the best
quarterback in the 90s in fact i don't
even know if that's an argument with the
mvps he won the great plays going to two
super bowls of course you know winning
one of them and losing an epic other one
uh and then just all the great years
after that trade i mean that that to me
would probably be uh that's a pretty
special trade brett favre is one of the
five greatest quarterbacks of all time
yeah i agree with you i think that's the
obvious first choice although john elway
may argue about best quarterback in the
90s he won two he won two troy aikman
may have an argument to make he won
three that said you're you're exactly
right it's
although what was it
what would you who would you take i'd
i'd i'd i'd go body of work
start to finish
man
i'd be i'd have to really go back and
think about between elway and farve
because
elway won two super bowls and he beat
farve right head to head i know it's
it's just one out of 46 guys but still
elway versus far of elway got the
victory with the elway copter move and
all that it'd be very close it'd be very
close
far far had another whole decade too
that elway didn't so uh
still pretty good and and he was never
traded so always irrelevant here i'm
gonna go with a guy that we already saw
that we already saw in uh the the b-roll
earlier of joe montana the guy standing
next to him when the chiefs were playing
the 49ers steve young steve young traded
by the tampa bay buccaneers back when
steve young who's he's the byu guy that
got the big contract with the la express
with the usf and he's never going to see
that money that's who he was before he
got traded to the 49ers then he became
steve young i mean he did nothing before
he got to the 49ers and then he did
everything after that so that's an easy
one for me it was brett favre and then
steve young so i think we got the first
two clearly out of the way now it gets
more interesting
well i thought you were going to go with
the guy we just talked about i mean
technically john elway i want to make
him my next pick is that okay he did get
traded from the colts to the broncos
you know and and
that if we're going to stay within the
rules of being you know best after the
trade
elway draws a line in the sand i'm not
playing for the colts i'm gonna go play
third base for the yankees of course the
colts eventually cave they trade them to
the denver broncos
and the rest is history i mean elway was
a superstar from pretty much get-go
there in denver i mean he's the the face
of that city the face of that franchise
still is
and to me certainly one of the greatest
quarterbacks i've ever seen in my in
person in my life or on tv or whatever
it may be i mean the 80s i don't care
that he didn't win any super bowl it's a
little bit like the lebron james factor
with john elway he brought some teams to
the super bowl that i don't think really
had a business being there but they were
there because he was so damn good he was
capable of you know overcoming that and
and you know
bringing their team through some clutch
moments so elway with five super bowl
appearances after the trade winning two
of them all the great things i'm going
with john elway as my second pick
yeah now look the lawyer in me would
argue that the explanation like that
that after that that best after being
traded implies there was actually
something before traded not just traded
right out of the gates never played for
the team it implies you actually played
for the team so so mini challenge flag
not the full blown challenge flag mini
challenge flag on that one but either
way you can have elway i'll take
marshall falk because marshall falk was
good for the
but he was great with the rams and i
remember at the time that trade went
down i thought man that is a steal
for the rams how what are the colts
thinking and any
look peyton manning had just gotten
there in 1990
and uh and goodbye marshall fox so um
look he he ended up and it was actually
1999 his first year with the rams who
had one year with with peyton manning
but he was the nfl mvp hall of famer one
of the key players in the greatest
show-offs on turf i mean the greatest
show on turf and uh yeah absolutely and
i think he's he's in the colts ring of
honor but he was better with the rams
than he was with the colts so give me
more yeah
good good pick by you really really is i
mean i mean marshall faulk was yeah i
was between him and elway for that next
one but i mean come on he won an mvp
with the rams he was special they built
that offense and a lot of what they did
successfully was because of his ability
to run the ball and catch the ball in
the backfield i mean he's definitely one
of the best running backs i've seen in
my lifetime as well man there's so many
good ones to pick pick uh from here
i i think the one though that which i
didn't even know this full transparency
okay but i when i saw it i was shocked
doing my research for this steve largen
you know i didn't realize steve largen
was drafted by the houston oilers i had
no idea
but then was traded during training camp
for an eighth and round pick and then
steve largent goes on and you know
ultimately for the seattle seahawks was
the all-time receptions leader in the
history of the nfl he went to
seven pro bowls i mean
uh most yards and touchdowns all-time
leader when he retired i mean that that
to me is pretty damn good so i know he
didn't really play a lot for houston
either way he was traded and after that
trade mr lawyer he had a hall of fame
career
i don't think he was ever on a regular
season roster with the houston army so
it's kind of in the same category as
john elway i'm going with a guy who was
traded twice
and who was better after
the second trade and he was traded back
to the team that traded him in the first
place
fran tarkin with the vikings
1961-67 traded to your new york giants
who then eventually traded him back and
it was three super bowls for fran tarkin
and once he returned to the minnesota
vikings in the 70s the cornerstone of of
a team that was close but no cigar all
too many times so give me friend target
and i i knew i could sandbag that one
until the very end
yeah i did not have that you know but
here's some other ones that i like mike
haynes remember mike haynes being traded
from the patriots to the raiders they
went on to win the super bowl that was
one of the best cornerback duos in
football i mean jerome bettis randy moss
were on my list
um
marshawn lynch would be another one uh
those were some of the biggest names i
had that you know we didn't get to here
in the draft one other guy who was
traded who comes up on the show from
time to time
paul krauss the deep safety who didn't
get over to help nate wright in the sh
and i know that if i talk about it long
enough it's going to come up again and i
really don't want it to but paul krauss
the all-time interception leader still
to this day traded by washington to the
minnesota vikings and if only he had had
truly been playing deep safety and
gotten over to assist then maybe maybe
that dude yeah yeah all right
december 28th of 1975. i thought if i
talked about it long enough they'd press
the button they didn't we're going to
take a break thank god more pft live
right after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports